bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur la
france est ce que vous êtes satisfait du
choix du 28 juin pour second tour des
municipales
bonjour je crois que le choix était très
difficile il n'y avait pas de solution
idéale et il fallait trancher entre
plusieurs difficultés
moi j'ai regretté je le redis encore
aujourd'hui sans doute pour la dernière
fois ce lobbying politique a été fait de
la part des maires sortants de certain
nombre de mes ressentant candidats pour
chercher avant même de connaître les
conclusions du conseil scientifique en
disant il faut voter à la fin du mois de
juin
donc j'ai trouvé cette précipitation
cette pression qui a été fait avant la
connaissance du rapport pas maladroite
indécente donc le contexte était celui
là depuis nous connaissons les
conclusions du conseil scientifique qui
sont d'une grande prudence
c'est un feu vert ou un feu orange mais
conditionnel avec une ce que
j'appellerais une clause de revoyure
quinze jours avant le scrutin
et je trouve normal et sain que le
gouvernement privilégie la tenue les
conditions sanitaires de la tenue de ce
scrutin c'est un contexte sanitaire
exceptionnel à un moment donné il faut
effectivement ont terminé avec cette
élection là mais il faut jamais perdre
de vue et c'est pour ça que je reproche
au maire qui sont intervenus dans cette
tribune du jdd dimanche dernier il faut
privilégier le contexte sanitaire
moi je ne veux pas d'une élection au
rabais je ne veux pas d'une élection
avec un taux de participation aussi
faible que celui qu'on a connu le 15
mars je pense que cela serait totalement
inacceptable d'un point de vue
démocratique cela ne sera pas la
sincérité du scrutin
vous allez avoir en moi devons vous
comment est ce que vous comptez tout
bêtement mené campagne auprès des
électeurs bordelais
alors il faudra être très inventif
c'est une première de faire une campagne
électorale dans un compte dans un tel
contexte sanitaire de distance physique
qu'il faudra observer avec nos
concitoyens et c'est sûr que nous serons
confrontés à certaines difficultés
pratiques pour convaincre les électeurs
et je suis à 100% d'accord avec
l'analyse qui a été faite par le
journaliste qui vient d'intervenir en
disant qu'il y aura incontestablement
une prime au maire sortant
ça c'est évident je dis ça explique
d'ailleurs le relais leur lobbying
récent il y aura surtout dans des villes
comme bordeaux ou si on est dans un
mouchoir
c'est à bordeaux est moins de cent voix
d'écart entre le maire sortant et la
liste que je que je préside
donc si vous voulez une élection
vraiment dans un mouchoir dont la prenne
au maire sortant
elle est là est tout le temps lui dire
le génie de notre campagne électorale
consistera à faire en sorte que notre
expression soit la plus importante
possible en utilisant naturellement mais
on peut pas se satisfaire exclusivement
les canaux je dirais numérique les
réseaux sociaux mais c'est pas les
réseaux sociaux qui feront l'élection et
qui feront la campagne électorale donc
une volonté de nous ouvrir aussi à tous
les électeurs quel que soit qu'ils
soient adeptes des réseaux numériques ou
qu'ils ne soient pas lésés site est
aujourd'hui aussi d'installer l'exécutif
locaux qui ont la main sur l'acompte
commande publique c'est crucial pour la
relance du pays aussi
oui ces peuples bien sûr c'est bien sûr
c'est un succès importants ce que je
n'ai pas très bien compris c'est
pourquoi est ce que le premier ministre
ait dit a éliminé d'emblée la date de
septembre
en dix ans pour davantage imposés ou
crédibiliser sa date de fin juin
il a dit ça sera fin juin ou sinon
janvier il y avait une alternative de
septembre octobre qui avait été
initialement envisagé qui à mon sens et
est parfaitement envisageable et qui
n'auraient pas été de nature à bloquer
l'activité économique du pays
l'été honnêtement espaces il se passe
pas grand chose je pense que ad limina
d'emblée le mois de septembre
le premier ministre a lui aussi fait
pression pour que la date du 28 juin
soit la plus naturelle sont la plus
naturelle possible
donc nous aurons en face de nous des
maires sortants qui ont pour certains
d'entre eux je ne fais pas de procès
d'intention mais je parle de ce que je
connais certains d'entre eux dont celui
de bordeaux ont profité je pèse mes mots
de cette période de confinement pour
faire une campagne électorale tous
azimuts je pense est aussi une exception
ici le maire s'est même acheté un
publireportage dans la presse locale
avec une diffusion boîte à lettres pour
montrer les réalisations et les
performances sans ses avants été
réalisée à bordeaux il a fait un faux ni
dans palette allant du phoning de madame
busin pendant la campagne électorale à
paris je peux vous dire ici que le maire
n'a pas attendu la campagne électorale
officielle
il a téléphoné à tous les bordelais pour
bien leur dire vous savez on est là
heureusement qu'on est là vous pouvez
compter sur nous c'est à dire vraiment
une campagne une campagne électorale en
prennent plus en plus près de
confinement dont il y aura une prime au
maire sortant qui sera encore plus forte
quand le maire sortant aura
manifestement joué habilement pose-t-il
de la paire de confinement et de
l'absence nous nous avons suspendu notre
campagne électorale au beau début
confinement oui on attendait en deux
depuis plusieurs saisons maintenant
cette bête aussi veille du second tour
des élections municipales maintenant que
cette date est fixée donc au 28 juin
quelles vont être vos premières
priorités
ces jeux ces jours ci en vue du
du second tour a alors on a profité de
cette période de confinement non pas
pour communiquer mais pour travailler
donc nous allons présenter au ban de
l'ex bordelais un programme électoral
qui sera pas fondamentalement différent
de celui du mois de mars mais qui sera
actualisé al'allure km et nouvelles
contraintes qui se sont imposés à
l'occasion de la crise que nous venons
de vivre donc un travail de rédaction
que nous avons heureusement largement
anticipée pour que la campagne
électorale coïncide le plus possible
avec les préoccupations les plus
contemporaines de nos de nos électrices
et des électeurs
donc on la récré on est en train de le
réécrire on va faire monter un certain
nombre de points qui n'étaient pas
suffisamment présentés comme des
priorités qui désormais le seront donc
si vous voulez on a travaillé davantage
les hiérarchies mais c'est sûr qu'on
avait déjà interrogé envie de dire que
tu es un peu adapté enfin on était les
seuls à parler quand même de crise
écologique de crise climatique et de
nouveaux mondes un nos adversaires resté
ancré dans l'ancien dans l'ancien monde
et qu'il s'agissait à peine 2
d'améliorer à la marche
bon nous nous avions anticipé que le
jour d'après serait très différent de la
veille
donc je pense que nous étions déjà un
peu en phase même si comme tout le monde
nous n'avions pas prévu naturellement
c'est cette crise et son ampleur mais
nous était en tout cas déjà un peu en
phase avec le fait qu'il fallait changer
de monde de notre slogan c'était le
monde change changeons bordeaux je pense
qu'il reste plus que jamais tout à fait
pertinents
merci beaucoup pierre hurmic elle
rappelle que vous êtes candidat
écologiste aux élections municipales à
bordeaux